Think restoring sight to the blind is only
a bible story?
Think again...
Hey there science fans!
Dr. Kiki from This Week in Science here for
DNews.
The brain is a wild and crazy place.
For years, scientists have thought that there
are periods of time during childhood, called
critical periods, when we have to have certain
kinds of experience in order for our senses
to develop properly.
For our visual sense, studies suggest that
the critical period for correcting any kind
of deficiency lasts from birth until about
2 years old.
After 2 years old, visual problems like amblyopia
- or lazy eye - for instance, can still be
reversed, but the success rate decreases the
older you get.
And, there seems to be a big difference when
treatments are attempted after around age
6.
The idea of critical periods in vision was
first tested by David Hubel and Torsten Wiesel
in the 1960’s by sewing kitten’s eyes
shut and measuring brain activity in the visual
cortex.
Totally gruesome, I know.
Anyway, they found that the neural pathways
connected to the closed eye were withered
in comparison to the normal eye, and that
they never developed vision in that eye, even
after the eye was reopened months later.
Because adult cats have fully developed visual
systems, sight could be restored even after
a year of having an eye sewed shut.
Hubel and Weisel won a Nobel Prize for this
work.
The concept of critical periods has to do
with the idea that “cells that fire together,
wire together.”
If your brain doesn’t get that early experience
of visual stimulation, the neural pathways
for vision won’t have a reason to link up
and create the system for vision.
In fact, it’s been shown that the visual
cortex itself begins to respond to other sensory
input, like sound and touch.
You might have heard of blind people who use
a form of echolocation that involves using
clicks and echoes to get around, even while
riding a bike.
Brain imaging shows that the brains of these
people are reorganized so that they “see”
the landscape based on what they hear.
So, knowing that the brain reorganizes in
this way, with other senses taking up the
neural real estate for vision, can that process
be reversed or is it really permanent?
An exciting study published in the Journal
of Neurophysiology this week by a research
team from the Universite de Montreal and the
University of Trento suggests that it can…
kind of.
The team imaged the brain of a 50-year-old
woman both before and after she underwent
surgery to implant an artificial cornea, called
a Boston Keratoprosthesis, in her right eye.
The woman had extremely low levels of vision
her entire life, and compared to people with
normal sight and those who lost their sight
later in life, she had both structural and
functional reorganization of the visual cortex.
Before the surgery, the visual area responded
to auditory input.
However, after the surgery, there was a significant
reduction in the auditory response, but it
wasn’t total, even after 7 months.
So, this study and others along these lines
suggest that some of the brain shaping that
takes place during the critical periods of
development is permanent, but some of it can
be reversed.
The trick now will be discovering what makes
the difference.
Do you want to help sight restoration research
happen?
You can!
By donating to Fight For Sight, an organization
that supports and inspires research in vision
and related sciences by granting funds to
scientists early in their careers.
What do you think of research like this?
Does it give you hope?
Tell us in the comments below or you can find
me on Twitter at Dr. Kiki.
And be sure to subscribe to DNews for more
science every day.